comment ça
va B va super travaillez bien premier
bain de foule et premier selfie pour le
nouveau Premier ministre Gabrielle Atal
et la ministre de l'Éducation et des
Sports Amélie ouea Castera pour leur
premier déplacement ensemble les
ministres se sont rendus au collège
saint-exupéri d'andrésie l'objectif
présenta leur nouvelle feuille de route
sur le choc des savoirs et réaffirmer la
volonté du gouvernement de rendre
l'éducation prioritaire l'école sera une
priorité absolu du gouvernement je sais
l'expérience que pour ce qui concerne
l'école comme dans beaucoup d'autres
domaines ce qui compte ce ne sont pas
que les mots ce sont les actes et donc
on va continuer à agir sans relâche pour
l'école de la République avec un
objectif absolu élever le niveau général
à l'école durant près d'une heure les
ministres ont pu échanger à H clos avec
les enseignants et les élèves la libre
parole a circulé entre les élèves les
équipes éducatives donc il a été
question de plusieurs sujets
à la fois la question de l'apprentissage
des fondamentaux et donc les élèves sont
revenus sur le dispositif mis en place
les bénéfices que ça pouvait leur
apportter et puis les équipes éducatives
comment elles étaient structurées une
façon aussi de rassurer les inquiétudes
concernant le double ministère dont
hérite Amélie oua casterra mon message
pour la communauté éducative c'est que
je seraai une ministre à fond une
ministre à fond avec eux une ministre à
fond derrière eux absolument déterminé
et je démontrerai à chacun de ces
acteurs ma disponibilité auprès d'eux
une année qui s'annonce chargée pour la
nouvelle ministre qui devra jongler
entre les défi de l'éducation et des
Jeux Olympiques et parinslympiques qui
se tiendront cet été